people haven't ask me how I know so many
people and so I tell them and when they
hear what I'm about to describe to you
this is what they say and I used to feel
that way too um so if this is you I want
you to know that it doesn't have to be
that way in fact it can become the best
part of your week if you give it a
chance I'm Libby herin and I'm here to
convince you to stop worrying about
networking and to just start making
friends networking is awful especially
if you're an introvert like I am we all
know connection is super super important
but maybe you just feel that connection
is daunting just like I did most people
who know me in our community would tell
you that I'm kind of a natural at
connecting with people I manage data
communities I host a podcast but if you
asked my husband he would tell you I am
in fact borderline
antisocial but in 2021 I got an
internship that was pretty much just to
meet a ton of people that was my job so
after four months of doing that job I
met over 100 new people oneon-one and at
that point asking for a zoom chat when I
bumped into somebody interesting online
was no longer awkward for me it was just
kind of what I did even though I was
still very very much an introvert that
experience showed me that at least for
me um meeting people just takes practice
right so what are we up against when
we're trying to make data friends first
of all you probably think you're not
very good at it which does not help I
believe in you I want you to let that go
that's a self-limiting belief so I'm
going to look back at my journey and
just share what helped me get
comfortable in the data Community
because I'd love everybody to have the
loving and supportive data family that I
have I'm going to share how I found
people that I clicked with how I got
them to engage with me and other people
and how I connected in an authentic way
that felt fun and not like complete
torture there's no one solution to any
of these problems we're all super
different people um but I'm going to
share what helped me so number one when
I was looking for people to connect with
this is going to sound super obvious I
went where the people
were people who are attending community
events whether they're online like the
posit data science hangout or in person
like uh your local art User Group those
people are there to meet people you
don't have to get over the barrier of
receptiveness right nobody goes to a
community event hoping oh my gosh I hope
I don't meet any people at this
community event if I joined a that
didn't feel quite right to me I just
moved on and tried another what do you
do when you check out a book at the
library and you don't like it do you
give up on reading no you take the book
back and you just get a different one if
I did connect with people in that
Community though I made sure to connect
on LinkedIn give Zoom chat going and
actually make a friend that's the goal
get to know somebody in person number
two when I look back at how I increase
engagement in communities to get people
talking I noticed that I was the one
frequently engaging myself in either the
chat or the live meeting because
communities tend to be sort of pay to
play I had to put myself out there I had
to turn on my camera I had to
participate you really have to do that
if you want people to be willing to do
the same people often say they don't
know what to say they I don't interact
because I don't know what to say
remember that data people like Puzzles
we like having our brains picked we like
challenges and that's what I did I
frequently brought my questions and my
challenges to the groups I was in
instead of just my accolades and my
presentations and my achievements
because if you wait until you have
something impressive to say you might
not ever say anything which leads me
very nicely to my third point when I was
struggling to make authentic connections
it was because I was too worried about
what people were going to think of me I
needed to practice
vulnerability I learned that fing
Perfection because you want to be
perceived well and being super
professional are just kind of
counterintuitive counterproductive to
making friends you might think that
perfect professional Geniuses are uh
impressive but what they are not is
relatable or
approachable so I started letting my
real life self just kind of ooze out
through the cracks of my professional
self my data professional self because
I'm a whole human being and so are you
shocker news flash giving people more
surface area to connect with sharing
more of myself with them really
increased my chances of seeing a spark
with people something that we could
connect on and this also means that I
didn't just stick to talking about data
right in fact if it if it helps this is
a list of things that I talk with my
data friends about regularly and none of
those are data data is the air we
breathe that's kind of boring at some
point we all do it we don't need to talk
about it all the time all right this is
a huge topic thanks for coming on this
journey of take two with me um and this
topic is really dear to my heart so I'd
love to chat about it more feel free to
come find me here in person or on
Discord and you can find more about me
on LinkedIn or my website datah humans.
Club where my tiny little podcast also
lives thank
you